The Joe Rogan Experience you can do that
with Budweiser though and you can do
that with like that's probably going to
happen with some other stuff too like
people are upset at the country music
channel
the Jason try that in a small town yeah
the level of outrage like now I'm not
saying that that's the greatest song the
world's ever known you know but the
level of outrage coming from people that
are upset about that song is so strange
when there are
hundreds of rap songs out there yeah
that are infinitely worse and also
enjoyable misogynistic qualifying
violence oh yeah yeah and no no
complaints at all yeah yeah yeah and
we're not even talking about old stuff
there's new stuff too there's there's
there's hip-hop there's Wild Rock songs
there's a lot of wild and to be
focusing on that one
and it it's the racial aspect of it it
was crazy because like the real antifa
problems that were happening during the
BLM I think it was a lot of white people
doing that right wasn't it it was a lot
of like lost liberal whites who are very
angry who decided to take up this
movement and smash things
so like the racial aspect of it there's
nothing racial about the lyrics or how
about the Tracy oh did you see the Tracy
Allman uh controversy no I did not so
she she wrote in the I don't know if you
remember in I think it was 1988 she had
this iconic song a fast car yes oh right
right right and then this uh I guess
he's a country music Chapman Chapman oh
that's she's an actress right she's a
comedian Tracy Chapman Chapman yeah and
then this this uh singer asked for her
permission I guess to to Luke Combs to
do a cover and so on it's amazing and
then people came out that you know the
white guy is a surfing this yeah well
but that's always going to happen you're
always going to have a certain amount of
people to say that yeah it doesn't mean
it's real
it's it also and apparently she's happy
that he's doing it well no kidding
everybody's good and it's a great song I
mean it's really good he didn't even
change the gender like when he sang it
yeah yeah you know yeah I can become a
checkout girl he says check out girl
right yeah yeah yeah yeah